hier soir le président macron a fait une
allocution événements aux français pour
traiter deux points très importants liés
par exemple à la crise du coc vide en
france
mais ce qui a retenu notre attention
c'est surtout sous le timbre de voix un
peu suave françaises français mes chers
compatriotes de métropole des outre mer
et de l'étranger un timbre de voix qui
nous anime il fait penser à autre chose
je sens bien quand je viens profondément
pas la souffrance de sa langue les alors
quelles en seraient les raisons le
président avait-il épuisé toutes ses
réserves de cordes vocales au cours de
ces dernières années alors ne vous
habituer
ou alors incarnera t-il dark vador dans
le prochain star wars notre objectif est
clair partout où l'attaquant joe roth au
final c'est pour une raison un peu plus
simple emmanuel macron souffre d'une
petite extinction de voix eh ben on lui
souhaite donc un bon rétablissement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le magnéto à fabien delhaye travaux un
coach vocal pour descendre du notariat
vent l'air plus chaud
vous qui avez fait beaucoup de télé ce
que vous avez pris des cours pour poser
votre nom proposez votre cul sur une
chaise non mais c'est vrai ça décolle de
centre de journalisme notamment que je
n'avais pas les accords louis
l'élocution l'élocution et moi j'ai vu
beaucoup de concours d'élocution non
c'est vrai alors c'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour mettre ainsi l'eau dans la
bouche c'est moi qui faisais week end
c'est vrai ah oui c'est bien on a vu
vous êtes sortie des premiers jours
à oui bref tout est ce à quoi mais alors
peut-être pas parlé mais aussi vos dans
la bouche
mais vous voyez vous la mettez une
trousse santé
[Applaudissements]
mais un sac à dos m'a
collé un truc de ouf nommé wang a fait
des études pour devenir animateur aux
journalistes ici non agents castagne
journalistes on sait qu comme vous
d'accord at home bio n'avait pas fait
d'études pas du tout baboo cette voie
oui d'abord qu'après j'ai appris le
lecteur à la superbe de journalisme
louis toulouze
l'école supérieure de journée à vélo oui
pareil voilà paris
[Rires]
j'ai fait la même école et le cmj bande
voilà centre de formation mais quand on
m'a recruté à rtl jeudi je peux pas
faire de la radio c'est horrible et ils
m'ont dit oui mais c'est pas mal et
reconnaissable
moi c'est faux je visais
après les métiers du cinéma perchiste
que caméraman à canal a appuyé le chétif
à san jose à florennes à l'époque
il ya page effet le centre de formation
des journalistes et en sortant j'ai
passé des tests à rtl pour présenter le
journal sakho mais j'ai été recalée à
quoi que ma voix
sa
mère dans sa tête et au corps
[Rires]
oui c'est le talent c'est le talent
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai et toi tu
as fait une école toi une école de mode
combat d'années selon la note était basé
que mon bac tu as que ton bac d'accord
et moi j'ai fait une école de commerce
mois en revanche j'ai pris des cours
pour articuler pour ma maman qui est
malentendante à et sur mes lèvres pour
ça qu'il ya c'est pourquoi tu es ba et
ba et ba prenez le stage ne se mêlent et
évoquer les nouvelles ou alors est ce
qu'elle a fait qu'elle ait vu toulouse
moi j'ai un parcours atypique mais par
contre j'ai une info sur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une info esthétique sur le président hu
est et je le seul à le savoir on peut le
savoir alors vous avez vu les chicots du
président elles sont plus en plus
d'heures les deux ans à venir alors
céder dans
dix ans quand même bien plus en plus des
espaces entre ses dents et en fait c'est
parce que le président il se fait
éliminer les chicots une fois par
semaine parce qu'il se prépare au
dentier non non la quarante trois ans
ces conneries vous allez en sortir
pour savoir parce que comment qu'on est
vraiment la pause ils ont bataillé à la
croix col red et vous n'avez pas vu de
plus en plus les années passent plus il
allait il a des trous entre les dents
mais non mais si oui
c'est fou non qui serait pas un bond
entier il va
revenir à quel âge alors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez que mon neveu
mais je
sais qu'elle s'appelle comment ton neveu
il s'appelle le julien et hilaire le
sommet ça ne va pas je me car le q2
tu leur as quand même c'est ton neveu
alors la forêt ou film est donc dû
bosser aussi alors je peux pas alors
c'est très joli mais ça n'est même pas
sortir avec une femme qui a des dents du
bonheur sa sortie reléguant sa part on
dit alors c'est pas du tout madame
béatrice dalle non non non merci j'aime
beaucoup la donne alors ça peut être
très fatigué on à l'emploi plus c'est
trop ouais bah c'est la langue c'est
pratique c'est très présent mais ces
bons qui passera du tout c'est bon
merci pour votre conseil beauté santé et
esthétique non non non et ça nous plaît
pas non la seule venue à un joli a bâti
sa part avait utilisé dont eckhard du
bonheur c'est la femme de mon ami faudra
lui qui aime beaucoup ses pattes de jean
dujardin ah bah oui
mais si c'est vrai que ça la voile âgées
et les malades style voilà dans métier
du monde voilà autant que ça très joli
final aussi bon merci